i do want to start out by saying i know
that you are giving love and sending
light to the refugees in ukraine so just
tell me about you i just want to
represent
the refugee crisis
let people
wake up and realize that this is a
humanitarian crisis the refugee crisis
is very real the displaced people are
very real
and they need help they need homes and
they need support
and there are oscar-nominated films flee
and kanto
which is which are about displaced
people so it's important president
zielinski
may make an appearance tonight and what
do you what do you hope to hear from i
hope that he says i need help and we
help him i mean what i what i hope to
hear from him is that
he's going to make the same pleas he's
been making since the first day of this
he needs help
our help he needs everybody's help he is
an incredible leader and thrilling to
see the need just keeps on coming it's
not getting any less so that that is
very true um i've never felt more
related or had a more relatable moment
with you than when the post you put up a
couple weeks ago about holding your
stomach in since you were 11. i when i
read that i said
lord thank you jesus for somebody
finally saying it and i let him exhale
at the same time
they're going to get her because i
promise you she will get you i will get
out you'll watch me exit so fast your
head will spin around like the exorcist
she'll look gorgeous oh my goodness me
jamie you talked about holding yourself
again but you were for so long
hollywood's like standard of beauty i
think back to perfect let me say this
i've for a long time have challenged
that standard i've been very vocal about
that that standard is such horse
and
that i have participated in the
exploitation of that standard and that i
no longer suck it in
quickly before we you get out of here
before we lose you you're going to
officiate your daughter's wedding in
world of warcraft cosplay i don't think
it'll be a wow cosplay i don't know i'm
gonna decide
just everybody back off it's all gonna
be good okay and you'll see it after you
just might
you